vous n'avez aucune idée du genre de conneries que les
gens font et tout le monde se
promène comme s'ils étaient dans une [ __ ] de
vidéo d'Enya vous détestez Wall Street mais peut-être
qu'il a fait trop vite j'aime mon travail vous
détestez votre travail j'aime mon travail Wall Street a
pris un  bonne idée il l'a transformé en une
bombe atomique de fraude et de stupidité marque
Baum le fougueux qui ne fait pas confiance au
système je vais vous dire à quel point je suis tu
es un connard il veut punir les
gens qui font la mauvaise chose comment  pouvez-vous
dormir la nuit en sachant que vous
escroquez les travailleurs, il est en quelque sorte
un héros improbable Je suis sûr que les banques du monde
n'ont pas été des incitations la
mère verte ne partage pas son opinion vous avez
tort ne souffrez pas des imbéciles le  les banques sont
devenues avides et je peux profiter de leur
stupidité dit la vérité kami maintenant
que je suis comme Mark si Morgan fait faillite
nous nous retrouvons avec rien je dis quand nous
vendons ce n'est pas à propos de vous ceci mais
bon côté derrière je dis  quand nous vendons Oh
toi